what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so it's been a while since we've done a
character explanation I really kind of
miss the idea of doing character
explanations team explanations by the
New Mutants are a really cool concept in
the realm of Marvel because they really
come out as a byproduct of the x-men
popularity which we'll talk about here
in a second but the New Mutants
originally appeared in Marvel graphic
novel number four and they were created
by Chris Claremont now the whole idea is
that this was done in 1982 and this
comes hot off the heels of the x-men's
popularity remember back when the x-men
were first created by Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby when Marvel was launching all
these publications in the early 1960s a
fantastic fourth or Iron Man ant-man
The Avengers the return of Captain
America spider-man different things like
that a lot of the comic book readers
that were coming to Marvel were already
at DC because a lot of the kind of book
publishers that existed they were trying
to publish superheros had largely faded
out by the time world war two came to an
end so from the mid 1940s going all the
way up into the early 1960s if you were
reading comics you were largely reading
DC and so Marvel found its foothold in
creating characters and concepts that DC
hadn't done before the problem with the
x-men was that when they originally
popped up they were teenage kids with
superpowers and while the superpower
element was new with regards to new you
know teenage superheroes for the most
part DC had covered a lot of that stuff
they had basically launched the Teen
Titans and so when the x-men ran up
until about issue number 63 I think it
was Marvel basically stopped printing
new stories and just ran reprints until
issue number 94 now in issue number 95
Chris Claremont took over the title
after the relaunch of x-men with
giant-size x-men issue number one and
because he focused on the team as more
of a soap opera because he focused more
on characters as opposed to adventurous
and zany stories like Stanley did the
x-men actually became Marvel's highest
selling publication and so because of
that seven years after their Arrakis
after this relaunch by Claremont are the
editor-in-chief of at the time Jim
shooter basically wanted to launch
another x-men title something that would
basically build on the success of the
x-men itself but have a wholly different
roster and so what Chris Claremont did
is he formed the New Mutants as a
throwback to the original x-men stories
that focused largely on the idea of
teenage kids who had developed
superpowers ended word
basically trying to figure themselves
out in the process now the only caveat
to this is a character named karma
character named Jan come on I think is
how you pronounce that I think that's
her name but she originally appeared a
Marvel team-up issue number 100 two
years before so she'd been around for a
couple of years before Chris Claremont
rolled her into the New Mutants but
because of her experience of the fact
that she'd been around for a while she
became the de facto leader but the long
and short of their whole of their whole
origin is that much like the original
x-men and much like mutants in general
their powers largely manifested in
response to a kind of stress of sorts
with regards to the character Wolfsbane
also known as rain Sinclar she can
literally turn herself into a werewolf
she had previously occupied a place
referred to as Muir Island which was
basically the base of operations the
home more or less of more McTaggart who
had long since been a standing friend of
the x-men kind of this mutant
geneticists this researcher who is the
scientific arm of the x-men team
alongside the you know beast Hank McCoy
now Force Wolfman gaining her abilities
simply just kind of popping up comes as
a byproduct of mutants at the time in
the sense that there was a lot of hatred
for mutants because humanity either
didn't like them because they were so
powerful or they didn't understand them
different philosophical viewpoints went
into that but Rayne Sinclair kind of
stumbled across the path of Moreh
McTaggart and she ultimately ended up
basically taking reign over to Charles
Xavier now the same thing happened with
Robert decosta a young kid based out of
Brazil who basically manifested the
ability to absorb solar energy and turn
it into a physical strength cannonball
Sam Guthrie from Kentucky much the same
way absorbs solar energy kind of able is
able to put off this thermal energy that
allows him to fly but this is how these
characters began manifesting their
abilities it is sort of popped up now
one of the big exceptions to this is
Danielle Moonstar when we end up seeing
her her powers have already popped up
and she basically has the ability to
create these sort of empathic illusions
to essentially get people to see things
that reflect her emotional state but the
idea is that they were all essentially
being targeted by a guy named Donald
Pierce now Donald Pierce and the movies
is just a guy who works in this part of
the project with regards to x-23 there
wasn't a whole lot going on to his
character in the Logan film in the
comics he's vastly different he is
basically a member of a group called the
Hellfire Club now the
Hellfire Club had been around Marvel for
quite some time they were basically one
of the various villain groups who had
been introduced in the x-men stories
under Chris Claremont in an effort to
basically bolster the various enemies
for the x-men to face off against but
for Donna Pierce himself unlike the
other members of the Hellfire Club who
possessed various powers Donald does not
have any abilities of his own instead
he's basically a cyborg of sorts but the
idea was that Donald Pierce was
essentially a fanatic who hated mutants
and for the longest time the Hellfire
Club was basically this sort of inner
circle of individuals who had the
ability to influence the world through
money and different things like that the
problem with this was that there was a
point along the line when the Hellfire
Club was co-opted by mutants they
essentially took over the ranks of the
Hellfire Club Donald Pierce hated this
concept and so the goal was to take the
new mutants use them for his own cause
to basically take over the Hellfire Club
and then get rid of the new mutants so
there wouldn't really be any challenge
to his cause the other half of this was
the ongoing stories of the x-men at the
time in the sense that the x-men were
experiencing this wax and wane under the
writing of Chris Claremont specifically
there were a handful of things that had
taken place the x-men were basically
often space fighting the brew they were
believed to have been dead Jean Grey had
already sacrificed herself during the
events of the Phoenix August she was
believed to have been dead these kind of
things hit Charles Xavier in a way where
he basically felt like he was a failure
as a leader as a father figure as a
teacher and so he ultimately didn't want
to teach the new mutants but more
McTaggart effectively persuaded him to
is to this cause and the result was that
he ended up taking up arms teaching the
new mutants as a new generation of
heroes who could in turn develop their
own fan base in their own core group of
readers
the other half of this is that with the
conclusion of the origin story for New
Mutants the defeat of Donald Pierce and
so on and so forth the idea of Marvel
was to look at the success of New
Mutants in terms of the actual origin to
gauge audience reception by way of
letters pages sales different things
like that and then decide whether or not
they were actually going to get a
publication which they did in March of
1983 with New Mutants vol 1 issue number
one now again with Chris Claremont
continuing the story over the course of
the first seven or so issues there was a
little bit of reshuffling in the sense
the Claremont was really just kind of
teasing the waters to see how people who
respond to different scenarios
explicitly with the death of karma now
the idea was that she did not really die
per se she was essentially possessed by
the Shadow King she eventually was used
by the Shadow King to go on and become a
gangster but it allowed Danny moon star
and Ken ball to take over a leadership
role in the team now again going on
after the first seven issues or so over
the course of the next seven usually you
know between issues 8 and 14 there were
some things that were sort of being
juggled around and some actions were
being taken by Claremont in an effort to
continue bolstering up the readership as
a really good example we actually ended
up seeing them come into contact with
the Hellfire Club but instead of seeing
them battle the Hellfire Club instead
Chris Claremont created a younger
version of the Hellfire Club which are
referred to as the Hellions now this was
huge for a lot of comic book readers at
the time because while Charles Xavier
believed the x-men were dead individuals
who were reading uncanny x-men knew they
weren't and so what it did is it gave
fans the best of both worlds because of
that some new changes were made to the
publications over the course of issues 8
to 14 we saw the introduction of
characters like cypher who is basically
a guy that could understand any language
whether it was written or spoken by the
character of magic Illyana Rasputin
which incidentally as the sister of
Colossus is her first major comic book
introduction in terms of anything past
her origin in giant-size x-men number
one we saw all these things going on
with these characters these new roles
being introduced these characters being
being allowed to stand on their own two
feet and fans were very much receptive
to it because Claremont focused just as
much on the storytelling of the
individual characters as he did with the
team itself at the same time when it
came to come about publications under
Marvel for the most part the only real
science fiction thing that you saw
was usually whatever stories involved
the fantastic for who may have been
exploring other parts of space or dr.
strange and so when New Mutants came
along and they were basically blending
in science fiction and fantasy it was a
great throwback to the 1950s to an era
of comics that a lot of readers were
nostalgic for but hadn't actually lived
in people loved New Mutants now at the
same time Chris Claremont was also
focusing on things like sort of this
redeeming story of magneto in the sense
that with uncanny x-men issue number 200
the trial of magneto the Charles Xavier
had essentially been taken away by the
Shiar Empire a spacefaring race that had
already been established in the x-men
series at the time and then magneto
himself took over a leadership of the
x-men now the problem with this was that
in a lot of ways existing members of the
x-men had basically left but the benefit
to New Mutants fans was that they were
basically teenagers doing what teenagers
did where magneto laid down rules
magneto said here's what you can and
can't do the new mutants would feature
stories where they would basically break
out escape the school they would go on
adventures they would save their friends
from all these different threats and a
lot of teenage readers could live
vicariously through them the problem
with this was that because new mutants
proved itself to be so wildly popular
among readers because of the fact that
the x-men itself was still wildly
popular at the time and Chris Claremont
was the de facto x-men guy Marvel began
tasking him with the role of launching
new titles new publications and so
ultimately Wolverine was a standout star
of the uncanny x-men Linus so he ended
up getting his own solo series under
Chris Claremont as well as the
introduction of Excalibur the British
superhero team and so as a result
Claremont actually took a break from New
Mutants with the intention of coming
back and the line was handed over to
Louise Simonson now when did it keep in
mind is that this coincides with the
return of Jean Grey which is to say
because Jean Grey had basically died as
the Phoenix and because she was so
incredibly popular in both the Phoenix
and Dark Phoenix saga fans wanted to see
her make her return but Jean Grey
alongside Cyclops angel beast and Iceman
had broken off from the original x-men
team and focused on basically a team of
their own titled x-factor and so with
new mutants serving as a younger more
vibrant companion to both uncanny x-men
and the x-factor line the roster was
bolstered even
and so things began to grow at an almost
rapid pace I mean we saw things like
rusty Collins Richter skids we saw these
characters being brought in and being
rolled over into the landscape and
things beginning to basically you know
shuffle and grow and increase even more
now depending on who you talk to there
is basically this idea that Louise
Simonson was essentially Mickey Marvel
unhappy in terms of her writing Marvel
because of the events of the death of
Gwen Stacy in 1971 the idea of the Dark
Knight Returns Marvel ended up moving in
this direction of crafting stories that
were darker that were more gritty over
on over-under Mary Jo Duffy with regards
to Power Man and Iron Fist for example
she was writing comedic stories which
Marvel didn't like so they fired her
they replaced her with curb music he did
the same thing they fired him then they
brought in a Christopher priest who
killed off Iron Fist
and then basically into the publication
with issue number 125 Louise Simon said
had come along and basically said it
seems to be the exact same thing that's
going on with regards to the New Mutants
line and so because that she ultimately
gave up with issue number 97 and the
result is that when she walked away Rob
Liefeld
and Fabien Miss Caesar were brought in
and they essentially relaunched the
entirety of the of the New Mutants line
now this only lasted for about about
three issues about three or four issues
issues 97 through 100 and the idea was
to basically finish out the New Mutants
line and then cancel the title as it
existed and relaunch it as something
else but under Liefeld and under
anesthesia because of the fact that the
early 1990s saw this huge paradigm shift
in comics in the sense of things were
becoming high-octane things are becoming
extremely fast paced and things were
really moving in the direction of being
like this you know super futuristic
which is one of the reasons why you see
a lot of characters from Marvel Comics
in the early 1990s wearing head pieces
and having a lot of gear that makes him
look impossibly large and things like
that but with Louise Simonson leaving in
issue number 7 and Rob Liefeld and
Fabian the season taking over a lot of
the existing plot lines as she had going
were effectively abandoned with you know
Rob Liefeld anesthesia picking up the
slack and so we're the futuristic son of
Madeleine Pryor and Cyclops cable had
actually appeared in New Mutants number
87 in March of 1990 while he was created
by Louise Simonson
the plot phrase is she had going in
terms of the overall
that she wanted to do with him were
effectively abandoned so where he'd
initially just sort of shown up as this
guy from the future that nobody really
knew anything about under Liefeld
anesthesia everything was effectively
reworked and so the original New Mutants
Ross or at least as it had evolved with
regards to boom-boom rusty Collins you
know Richter skids those guys it
eventually went away instead they were
replaced by uh by domino ferrule shatter
star and warped half now of course this
goes until like the origin of Deadpool
the fact that the version of Domino that
we saw was not actually Domino instead
it was a character named copycat who is
impersonating Domino these are the kind
of things that eventually went on in
those stories but the problem with this
was that with issue number 100 canceling
New Mutants and the story's being
relaunched while the stories were
initially extremely popular the problem
with this was that the value of New
Mutants began to go away because of the
fact that x-men vol 2 issue number one
continued to be one of the highest
selling comic books of all time because
uncanny x-men saw Chris Claremont
leaving within the first 10 issues I
think it was Jim Lee leaving shortly
after we ended up seeing all these
things coalescing to the point where
Marvel was running headlong into the mid
1990s comic bust with a lot of their
stories losing their value now for the
living eyes you don't know the the 1990s
comic bust was basically a byproduct to
the fact that people believed the value
of comics would rise forever and so they
just went out and bought a whole bunch
of comics thinking they would just hold
value for years and years and years and
years the result is that kind of the
publishers began flooding the market
with comics believing that they were
just ever more popular when in reality
fans were artificially inflating the
market now DC Valiant Comics all these
companies were affected by the mid-90s
comic bust but DC was backed by Warner
Brothers Marvel was not which meant that
if their stories ultimately went under
they would have shut their doors or they
would have had to sell out to somebody
but back during this point in time
because the sci-fi escapades the
alternate realities all these
science-fiction elements had basically
gone away in favor of a series of
stories that just dealt with super high
action high-octane events ultimately
meant that x-force began to kind of go
away running into 2002 it remained
relatively popular the problem with this
was that things began to drop off and so
ultimately Marvel had to begin going
through and start making concessions as
to what comic books were going to
the longest to ultimately become
successful and so beginning in 2003
under none zo de Philips I think it's
how you pronounce his name
I believe that's who it was New Mutants
was basically relaunched and the idea
was to keep x-force going but to focus
on the concept of New Mutants as
basically this new modern era of
characters who would basically begin
going through and running through their
own stories the funny thing about this
though was that it was not initially
launched on its own and said what ended
up happening is that with Grant Morrison
being brought in by Marvel Comics after
his run on JLA in 1998 as well as things
like you know Doom Patrol and so on at
DC Comics he was tasked with relaunching
the x-men in 2001 and so writing the
stories as new x-men and the Academy X
number two spin-off the new mutants were
basically reintroduced as vol 2 and so
ultimately again under the under NIMS EO
we ended up seeing everything sort of
brought back we saw new characters being
introduced existing characters coming
back so the roster grew to include
people like elixir this omega-level
mutant that can basically heal anybody
from any kind of harm they might sustain
we saw all these things being brought in
the problem with this was that seeing a
younger generation of superheroes was
not new the stories had to be done in a
way that drew people in the problem is
that these stories as they were written
didn't really do a whole lot to keep the
readership there and so ultimately it
ended up lasting around 13 issues up
until 2004 when Marvel launched House of
M now the idea of House of M was to
basically look around under the eave you
know the editor in chief leadership of
Joe Quesada to look around Ennis and
simply say the x-men landscape has grown
too large and too unruly there's too
many mutants out there and it takes away
from the ability to tell compelling
stories Marvel came back and just
reduced the mutant population by a huge
amount essentially saying that of the
100 and however many students there were
at the Xavier Institute only like
20-something actually kept their powers
and so what this did is it allowed
Marvel to focus back down on the on the
new mutants landscape as it existed you
know after the events of house of M and
tell more compelling stories now in
truth the new mutants for the most part
vanished after that what Marvel ended up
doing is they came back in 2009 and they
effectively relaunched it under Zeb
wells it was really just kind of going
back to the
core roster - really the most popular
roster as it existed by combining the
first two groups of the New Mutants so
we basically ended up getting cannonball
karma magma Danny moon star and sunspot
coming together to help reform the team
this really just kind of existed
alongside the events of like ex furnace
you know so on and so forth these
stories the idea that the x-men had
basically left the United States taken
up residence in utopia off the coast of
San Francisco and so again the idea was
to bolster the stories to keep them tied
into existing things and then in turn
keep the New Mutants title popular among
readers again the issue here is that we
ended up seeing the New Mutants line
begin to lose popularity yet again when
we started seeing events like Second
Coming and the new generation of mutants
who were brought in after new mutants
called generation Hope under Hope
Summers the first mutant born after the
events of house of M and so because the
late 1990s going into the 2000s and the
2010 s was basically just this giant
hotbed this huge mess when it came to
like all these different X related
titles ultimately the value of the of
the new meatless line again began to
fade because the characters just weren't
really compelling anymore at the end of
the day it just never really seemed to
serve a unique purpose and so ultimately
Marvel's last attempt to really revisit
the New Mutants line came during the
events of x-men schism and this was a
story that basically dealt with the idea
that Wolverine and Cyclops had two
distinctly different ideologies in terms
of how the x-men should be led and so
ultimately they had this feud of sorts
they ended up splitting that led into a
story called Regenesis which basically
gave us the Jean Grey school of higher
learning under the leadership of wool
frame and then utopia under the
leadership of Cyclops and for the most
part the younger mutants who were being
trained by Wolverine we saw some of them
stay with him we saw others staying with
with Cyclops and so the new mutants
didn't really exist anymore they were
just kind of you know younger mutants
who were being trained by both sides
both of whom had completely different
ideologies but again yeah just wanted to
kind of throw this out there with a
little bit of tidbits of information out
there for you guys with regards to the
new mutants landscape if you are new
here to come this explain make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
kind of a lot to throw at you guys but
there is a lot of interesting history
there so it's kind of weird getting back
on the horse and doing character
explanations again but with that being
said guys uh yeah we're gonna go and
bring this video to an end and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]